loria il ya plusieurs chemins il faut
d'abord voir que cette première
immigration italienne socialement une
vibration de gens venus du nord qui
émigrent depuis très longtemps et qui
évidemment arrive plus massivement à
partir de 1880 1890 beaucoup d'entre eux
ils viennent d'emilie viennent surtout
du piémont il ya des pieds travers ses
alpes parfois en plein hiver
quelques-uns reste en route
ensuite il remonte le long de la vallée
du rhône de la saône jusqu'en région
parisienne m'a pied quelques-uns mais
beaucoup aussi par chemin de fer
d'ailleurs il s'emploie au fur et à
mesure de leur montée vers paris se dire
qu'ils vont bien souvent sur la ligne du
plm de chantier en chantier jusqu'à la
région parisienne où il se fixe à partir
de 80 90 de manière encore retrait rôle
très lâches
s'ils sont peu nombreux il ya eu notre
émigration qui viennent plus loin qui
vient du sud se sont d immigration
immigration de deux jeunes enfants des
adolescents cela vienne du napolitain de
basilicate
il s'embarque à naples il arrive à
marseille et de là ils remontent vers
paris ils sont souvent très mal traités
recruté par des espèces de son appel cap
hincapie maestre des sergents recruteurs
que dans quelques centres les acheter à
leurs familles par petits groupes de dix
ou douze qui remontent jusqu'à 1 à
naples où jusqu'à gênes de là ils
s'embarquent pour marseille les filles
quelquefois vont grossir les rangs mena
prostitution marseillaise
les garçons sont acheminés vers paris on
va les employés soit dans les verreries
soit dans des petits boulots comme on
dirait aujourd'hui vendeur de statue
d'albâtre
montreurs d'animaux ou beaucoup d'entre
eux sont également très mal traités et
ne reviendront pas bien souvent de ce
terrible en terre de france et en ile de
france
[Musique]